nuevo incidente en el espacio aéreo
norteamericano el gobierno canadiense
anunció el derribo de un objeto no
identificado descrito como pequeño y
cilíndrico sobre el territorio del yukón
en el norte del país
el objetivo volaba una altitud de 12 km
había entrado ilegalmente en el espacio
aéreo canadiense y suponía una amenaza
razonable para la seguridad de los
vuelos civiles
Hoy es un día histórico Canadá y Estados
Unidos seguirán trabajando juntos a
través del mundo binacional del norad
para defender a nuestras dos naciones
el objeto fue derribado por un casa
estadounidense en el marco del norad la
fuerza de defensa compartida
estadounidense canadiense eso se produce
un día después de que Estados Unidos
llevará a cabo una acción similar sobre
su propio territorio en Alaska el objeto
era aproximadamente del tamaño de un
coche pequeño por lo que no es similar
en tamaño o forma al globo de vigilancia
de Gran altitud que fue derribado frente
a la costa de Carolina del Sur el 4 de
Febrero el 4 de Febrero un casa
estadounidense derribó lo que Washington
denominó un globo de vigilancia chino
después de que sobrevolara
emplazamientos militares sensibles china
afirmado que se trataba de una esfera
aerostática cumpliendo funciones
científicas principalmente
meteorológicas provocando una nueva
ruptura diplomática entre las ya tensas
relaciones entre las dos naciones las
autoridades estadounidenses y
canadienses ahora trabajan para
recuperar y analizar los restos de estos
dos últimos objetos voladores para poder
entender sus capacidades y orígenes